Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
If we have an animation movie or a computer
game where, like in any other digital medium,
we wish to have high-quality, lifelike animations
for our characters, we likely have to use
motion capture.
Motion capture means that we put an actor
in the studio, and we ask this person to perform
cartwheels and other motion types that we
wish to transfer to our virtual characters.
This works really well, but recording and
cleaning all this data is a very expensive
and laborious process.
As we are entering the age of AI, of course,
I wonder if there is a better way to do this?
Just think about it...we have no shortage
of videos here on the Youtube about people
performing cartwheels and other moves, and
we have a bunch of learning algorithms that
know what pose they are taking during the
video.
Surely we can make something happen here,
right?
Well, yes, and no.
A few methods already exist to perform this,
but all of them have dealbreaking drawbacks.
For instance, this previous work predicts
the body poses for each frame, but each of
them have small individual inaccuracies that
produce this annoying flickering effect.
Researchers like to refer to this as the lack
of temporal coherence.
But, this new technique is able to remedy
this.
Great result!
This new work also boasts a long list of other
incredible improvements.
For instance, the resulting motions are also
simulated in a virtual environment, and it
is shown that they are quite robust - so much
so, that we can throw a bunch of boxes against
the AI, and it still can adjust to it.
Kind of.
These motions can be retargeted to different
body shapes.
You can see as it is demonstrated here quite
aptly with this neat little nod to Boston
Dynamics.
It can also adapt to challenging new environments,
or, get this, it can even work from a single
photo instead of a video by completing the
motion seen within.
What kind of wizardry is that?
How could it possibly perform that?
It works the following way.
First, we take an input photo or video, and
perform pose estimation on it.
But this is still a per-frame computation,
and you remember that this doesn't give us
temporal consistency.
This motion reconstruction step ensures that
we have smooth transitions between the poses.
And now comes the best part: we start simulating
a virtual environment, where a digital character
tries to move its body parts to perform these
actions.
If we do this, we can not only reproduce these
motions, but also continue them.
This is where the wizardry lies.
If you read the paper, which you should absolutely
do, you will see that it uses OpenAI's amazing
Proximal Policy Optimization algorithm to
find the best motions.
Absolutely amazing.
So this can perform and complete a variety
of motions,
adapts to more challenging landscapes, and
do all this in a temporally smooth manner.
However, the Gangnam style dance still proves
to be too hard.
The technology is not there yet.
We also thank Insilico Medicine for supporting
this video.
They work on AI-based drug discovery and aging
research.
They have some unbelievable papers on these
topics.
Make sure to check them out, and this paper
as well in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!